as we say goodbye warm weather the five
shorts and t-shirt we'll see you soon
Toronto and we get the document that
experience coming up
[Music]
ah I believe nation this is officially
our last day of vacation how was the
sleep last night
yeah enjoy the hotel yeah
didn't had too big a TV I don't know
about this Hayden getting his own TV
it's a little sad cuz it's our last day
we're gonna go downstairs
jump up our bags get some breakfast
hopefully hit up some little havana and
then get ready to go to the airport
come on home to Toronto and chemo
[Music]
all right we made it
Little Havana
so note to self on the Sunday morning
everything in Little Havana is closed so
we're looking for food and we're gonna
go to this place that I've never heard
of called Polo chem panel how they not
open maybe not stay tuned pollo con pero
is closed very sad
maybe that means we have to go across
the street to McDonald's looks like
we're gonna have some authentic Cuban
McDonald's food that's why we can't do
Little Havana
all right breakfast up we got some
coffee
we've got some whatever this is
pancakes more pancakes hash browns time
to eat it's my happy team Blue Jays who
has a joke to tell
[Music]
a muffin joke what's the muffin joke oh
my god I like
so there's a really famous Cuban place
called Versailles which is strange
because that's a French name but anyway
highly recommend the place to go check
out some food we had our McDonald's but
we're not giving up on getting some
authentic little havana food or Nina if
she wants it so we're gonna make it
happen
I hope believe
[Music]
all right let's see what you ordered
Nina there it is
moment of truth authentic Cuban food
from Little Havana
Oh two beef empanadas and two cannolis
mm all right give it a shot Nina yeah me
yeah oh it's really good I like it
okay cannoli time
not actually I thought we lost okay a
little cleaner all right we were done
with the Versailles yummy treats thank
you very much
we saved the day with some authentic
Cuban food now we're gonna hop an uber
get back to the hotel and head to the
airport
[Music]
we have to finish the cannoli an
empanada as we say goodbye warm weather
goodbye shorts and t-shirt Nina
accidentally tried to bring in some
water and a tumbler so we've got it
she's got to leave the terminal and come
back in Hayden has been recruited to the
u.s. security service as a what does it
say again junior officer so does that
mean we have to listen to you now while
we're at the airport havens in charge
mister junior officer here she is the
troublemaker we got stopped in Paris
because Annina bring it on too many
liquids that is good times and she had
to go through again but we're here and
we've lots of time to board our plane
Nina we found the Starbucks look H five
at the top Oh Angie seven look at that
double Starbucks let's see where we're
going Toronto Toronto on time j5 let's
go
here's our j5
so we're gonna hang out yeah
what's dead ahead
Starbucks we're gonna get something for
mommy Nina alright let's go
there it is friends wait a minute why
are there two straws what you just drank
from both you just touched my straw look
it turned my straw green but it is your
head hmm
Hayden is over there making a video
what's your video called spy mission
mini director in the making right here I
love it
so still got a little bit more time
before heading on the plane I'm gonna
get on social media start replying to
all the Instagram comments that have
been piling up walls away and I'm
excited to see you guys have the same
Hayden is so ready to go home big smiles
so happy and we'll go again next year
which is so close
[Music]
we are back look at that smile
she's happy we're home but also
highlight coming up is we get to see
Timo play with him she's me very excited
team was gonna be very excited too
and we get the document got experience
coming up all right well it is Sunday
night we came home we relaxed we had
showers we did a bunch of laundry that's
behind there I shaved yeah I know I had
a haircut so that's good we got to see
Timo my camera cut out of memory I ran
out of storage space just as we were
brick coming home and see Timo the
climax there but luckily Jer I still
caught some footage so you can see the
excitement both the Timo excitement and
the Nina excitement to see the team we
miss this little guy has another trip
for you highlight helps relax your
highlight was relaxing yeah well you can
relax here I think the highlight for me
was the I like the dolphin reggae how
much everybody liked him or how much
he'd like to do
yeah reggae was fine I think just Haydn
and the family and everybody together it
worked out pretty well better than I
expected to be honest I expected be
frustrated with how things might go
slowly because I like the rush rush but
because I was sick for a good chunk of
it yeah
or nauseous then I didn't want to go
fast and so it all worked out anyway
thank you guys for joining us on our
adventures in the Caribbean we are super
happy to be home and back to our normal
life now
No yay we hope you had a great weekend
we believe in you continue to believe
and whatever you want where is much love
we'll see you soon bye